[Music]
we're gonna be given a very strong
report as to exactly what we think
happened and I think it'll be very
conclusive is there any suggestion that
it was anything nefarious or that it was
just a mistake so I think they made
personally I think they made a horrible
mistake and they didn't want to admit it
we wanted to go in they didn't want us
there even world health wanted to go in
they were admitted but much later you
know not immediately and my opinion is
they made a mistake they tried to cover
it they tried to put it out it's like a
fire you know it's really like trying to
put out a fire let's bring in Newt
Gingrich Fox News contributor and former
Speaker of the House an author of Trump
versus China facing America's greatest
threat good morning to you good morning
good morning so do you I've heard so
many different opinions about this the
president's saying that they were trying
to stock up on or the government's
telling us that they were trying to
stock up on their medical supplies
that's why they didn't want the rest of
the country to know that's why they
waited you know almost a week to tell
everyone I've also heard the theory that
they're such a powerful country they
wanted to they didn't want to be the
only ones that were affected by this and
the economy was affected only in China
so they didn't tell the rest of the
world what do you think well I think we
don't know some of their motivation but
we know what they did and I think if the
Chinese wanted to clear this up the
dictatorship could allow American and
other Western scientists and medical
doctors to visit Wuhan to visit the labs
to interview the people involved I think
secretary Pompeo
was almost certainly right when he said
that the preponderance of evidence now
is that it came out of the military labs
he did not come out of the markets and
if that's true that raises some very
serious questions of the long period of
people warming about the Chinese labs
that they're very badly run they're very
unstable that people have a real
propensity to leak out of them and you
have to recognize you're talking about
probably by the time this is over more
than 400,000 people worldwide will have
died because of the Chinese dictatorship
this is directly the fault of
dictatorship which as early as November
at its first cases and as early as the
middle of December began to realize that
there was an epidemic in Wuhan and lied
to the entire planet until very late
January and is never allowed any of the
Western scientists or doctors to come
into Wuhan and find out what happened so
I think the burden of proof with them
the Chinese and I think that frankly the
Congress ought to be holding hearings on
this we ought to be adopting legislation
to allow Americans to sue the Chinese
government for their loved ones and
without are we looking at reparations
from China I think the Germans have
indicated they think the Chinese own 149
billion dollars for the damage they did
to the German economy the amount here
would be encountering bigger yeah of
course not only has the United States
States been hit so hard
Newt you were there in Rome Italy the
good news is after eight weeks the
lockdown is going to be lifted today
four million Italians who work in
construction and manufacturing are going
to go back to work
speaking of going back to work the
Senate the US Senate it's going to go
back to work at 3 o'clock this afternoon
but the US House is not because Nancy
Pelosi the speaker used to be your job
says it's not going to do it right now
well I think I saw something correctly
this morning she has indicated it
probably gonna come back next Monday I
think that there's no excuse for either
the house or the Senate not to be in
session you can't ask the rest of
America to take risk every truck driver
every grocery store clerk you know every
first responder lots of millions of
Americans are taking risk and it's
reasonable to ask our elected officials
in a prudent way following social
distancing washing their hands and when
appropriate wearing a mask but it's
still I think they ought to be at work
and they ought to be really paying
attention both to the Chinese role but
also to what's happening at home
so let's switch gears just a little bit
and talk about the pandemic response
obviously Joe Biden does agree with
any of it he had to combine with
Elizabeth Warren kind of interesting
combination there to write in editorial
and it said this there's no oversight
someone here's an excerpt there's no
oversight of the coronavirus relief
because that's what Trump wants a quote
from the op-ed Trump seems to think he
can direct funding for the response to
the crisis based on which politicians
are nice to him which states he's trying
to win in November and which businesses
he wants to enrich or that any
accountability we have a different view
that is not the case at all no one's
really said that but he has pointed out
when he feels it like the governor of
Illinois who seems very hostile and he's
not really pulling off the most
efficient performance but do you think
that's an accurate portrayal and what do
you think of that combination of those
two writing together
well look I just went through all of
yesterday's interviews the Democratic
governor of New Jersey was praising
Trump Governor Cuomo in New York has
praised Trump even the governor of
Illinois admitted that the federal
government had come through with a lot
of resources a governor Newsom in
California Democrat has praised Trump so
I think that Biden has gotta say
something it doesn't matter whether it
makes any sense or not and I think he's
in a difficult spot right now so I think
he's do you have to assume he'll attack
the president but the fact is when the
president correctly cut off travel from
China
it was Biden who attacked it and said it
was racist it was in a phobic so Biden's
got to look back and say you know was
Trump right I think anybody agrees he
was was Trump right or should we have
fun with the Biden policy with allowing
another couple hundred thousand Chinese
to fly in bringing with them the
pandemic all right new thank you so much
for joining us good to be with you thank
you